ready for revolution is the
autobiography of the late civil rights
leader Stokely Carmichael published to
coincide with the fifth anniversary of
his death it's this week's public lives
feature this program lasts an hour thank
you and good evening
and I would like to thank you for coming
out under the threat of snow I went to
school in a stone so I know that went
snow threatens the town closes down in
fact the only editorial I can remember
from the Washington Post during that
period was an editorial commented on the
fact that an inch and a half of snow had
fallen and all the schools in the
district who were closed but all the
racetracks were open so I am happy and
pleased to see you here on these
occasions and they're joyous occasions
for me to go around talking about Kwame
Toure Stokely Carmichael's book and of
course a Myra - I probably refer to him
as Stokely since that's how I first met
him and I so he comes to my tongue when
I talk it's a joyous occasion because in
some respects the existence of the book
is quite a miracle and I'll talk about
that in a little bit but they one abide
in area of sadness is that the man who
should be standing here talking to you
about that book is not with us but he is
with us in spirit because the spirit is
in that book and that book is something
of his legacy to us it's been my honor
to be able to work on it to arrange it
to organize it to present to you but
those of you who know admire and love
the brother will know and see very
clearly without anybody calling it to
your attention that his spirit is there
his languages there his courage and his
extraordinary width and eloquence is in
the book I have nothing to do with that
I just had the great literary genius to
get out of the way
and although the brother to tell his
story in his own terms so even though it
is coming to you at some time after his
passing five years to be exact it is an
autobiography it is a is his account of
his life of his struggles or his abiding
concerns of his abiding commitments and
what led him to think and act the way he
did and that is in its own terms
one of the remarkable human stories of
our time and a very inspiring testimony
if I had a contribution it's because I
don't have the talent I don't have
sufficient literary talent do I know
some writers who do to render comic
whose extraordinary story does it would
take much more talent than I have to
make it does so it's a very exciting
read of a book and that is tribute to
comic of charisma courage and
personality I omitted to do one thing
that I should've done when I first
started we have among us we have with us
today Stokely Carmichael's son Booker B
row which it's not you're looking at me
with an expression very reminiscent of
his father's would you greet the people
rather and I didn't expect to see when
I'm surprised delighted I'm very happy
to see when I last saw him he was 14
years old and very different have begun
by saying that the existence of this
book is something of a miracle and I'm
not particularly religious I don't tend
to furthermore spot speak in those terms
but I think they are appropriate on this
occasion and I'll very quickly tell you
why I think that is so on one level it's
a political miracle if you look at the
book it's coming out from a major
American host scriveners a branch of
salmon and Schuster itself a part of the
conglomerate Viacom which also owned CBS
so it is a immediate octopus the
corporate media that we hear about a
part are the establishment of this
country why is that significant
well because the book isn't coming out
from a University Press it's not coming
out from a nationalist host somewhere in
Harlem it's not inspired in those and
it's not coming out from some leftist
press on the fringes of the society the
books coming out from the heart of the
establishment and that's a miracle
because it's the same establishment that
during our brother's life and struggles
I wouldn't use the word conspire back I
wasn't conspired they can tried very
openly to try to marginalize them to try
to diminish his political contributions
to diminish his historical and political
significance and render him in political
and cultural terms a persona non
existent and yet here we have them
published in his honor dr. etude on
censored artoo biography the
autobiography not just of a black
militant but of a black revolutionary
thinker and activist without censorship
without amendment without change and a
question is why would the establishment
give a platform to a black revolutionary
a black radical I've never answered that
question but the truth is the judgment
of one publishing house and one
publisher words that Carmichael's
testimony needed to be published and
they would support and endorse that
effort so I'm very grateful to that and
I didn't have anything to do with the
right and or the composition of the flap
copy well here we have the same
establishment that had been at such
pains to to diminish and reduce
Carmichael's presence and importance
saying to begin with
by any measure Stokely Carmichael Kwame
Toure fundamentally altered the course
of history
this long-awaited autobiography fills a
yawning gap in the American historical
record as it chronicles the legendary
civil rights leaders work as chairman of
Snickers cetera etc it's an unflinching
searing often visionary testament to the
man's legacy and joins the work of
frederick douglass WB Dubois Malcolm X
and Nelson Mandela as a crucial and
colorful contribution to contemporary
history as in life the Carmichael in
these pages is a definition of charisma
and determination ready for revolution
captures as few books ever have the
pulse of the cultural upheavals that
define the modern world regardless of
whether one subscribes to Carmichael's
politics and ideas I guess they had to
put a little disclaimer in there there
is no denying the overwhelming influence
he had on American lives in history and
his view from the eye of the black
struggle storm is invaluable so that's
the first thing you all I don't have to
remind you of the state of the American
corporate world today the attitudes
which provided the political beliefs
which are at the heart of their
activities so to have this coming out as
mildly miraculous the major miracle law
is that it book exists at all when we
begun to talk about doing such a book
brother camara was already stricken with
a very aggressive form of cancer and the
best medical opinion did not give him a
year to live beyond that year he lived
another 18 months during much of that
time I was with him
as he left the Testament testimony Auto
which this book could be made and during
that time I had reason to develop an
even greater admiration
for his courage and his determination
many a night he'd be taping in terms of
the tape recorder when I was exhausted
and went to bed and he was the one who
was terminally ill I remember one night
in Florida and his mother's hosts they
had changed as his spin medicine has
been prescription and the new
prescription was not effective and it
was very hot when it was hot Florida
night it's a perspiration or streaming
off him
I could seep in and anguish in his face
and and he had his tape recorder and I
said Carmichael maybe they could give
you something to push it to sleep you
could get some rest and he does push the
piano and said North I but I got to
finish this work I've got to finish this
work and it was that determination that
left the material Oh to which this book
could be created and I think he did it
not in the manner of most political
autobiographies as some kind of a
champion advertisement for himself he
wasn't running for any office not to set
the old scores not to refight old
battles and certainly not to glorify his
contribution there was none of that kind
of overt egotism and self serve aspect
in what he was telling me he considered
it an eyewitness account of history that
observed and he says very from the gates
right up front is as only the people
make history this is an account of my
brave struggle and suffering people and
when you read the book you see that that
is the kiss
it's not about comic that is about as
people's about the struggles about
higher principles and it's about
enduring values which is what in fact
defined his life
quite contrary to the stereotypes and
reductive myths created about him in the
national media so for that reason
there's no question in my mind that he
left that as his testimony to
to us and to future generations his
legacy let us see what he himself says
the very first chapter he sent me the
very first chapter his sentiment begun
with these notes what we are writing
here is history or at least a personal
account of an eyewitness to history or
rather Jimmy Baldwin peace be on to him
use the constant to tell us and sneak
that you all have to be a witness that
is all we are doing here bearing witness
to what we have done and seen in the
hope God willing that it will prove
instructive to those who follow us and
it was president Ahmad secretory peace
be on to him on to his fat and spirit
who unfeelingly reminded us that quotes
only the people make history it is not
individual heroes not individual
geniuses but all of the people who make
history that I think is a fundamental
belief of common belief of gamma echoes
and it informs and pervades this whole
narrative I have never forgotten his
teaching so you should understand that
more than anything else this is an
account of my people my remarkable
heroic struggling people who are
supported inspired and protected me in
all my years of strife I suppose very
first words he sent us to be put in this
book and that spirit is maintained
throat there are two other things I'm
going to talk about very briefly though
I won't stop talking what I'll do then
is take a question then speak to
whatever it is you want to know when I
think about my friend a Mac rather which
is what he was Tim as never his father
so I have no ambitions our intentions of
picking up the mantle of Carmichael or
his heritage he asked me to do one thing
I have done it and I think I've done it
in a chord
those instructions which are very
extensive and very clear but the two
things he used to say was well what are
they what are the two things which he
left with us I know you would say that
being a member of the party but
preceding that his most fundamental
beliefs what we got to have is undying
love for people I'm down low for people
we comical ours rhetoric he meant every
syllable of every word of that and his
life is a demonstration of that
principle in action
and that is as admirable as it is
unusual and the time in which we live
and there was another thing he used to
say if you work for the people
if you struggle for the people finish
the sentence never abandon the people
see that you like nothing new people
will provide now when most people say
that it sounds like I remember most
people don't say that when most people
hear that is what I meant to say they
hear it as sentimentality and rhetoric I
never heard it that way because that
worked in the south and I know exactly
what he was talking about had worked and
snake among some of the poorest people
on this in this country and had seen
exactly what he meant so I understood
what he meant but I remember one rally
in Chicago where he said that that's
after he was strict and said it a number
of times I know this brother sitting
there saying I'm worse than her people
didn't do nothing for me and as lady sit
next to sister the classic rioting no
jism and come back I might have said it
again a suspect I believe and the guys
and if he Fisher and don't [ __ ] for me
and we don't move and it's little turn
to you and said yeah but you know what
have you done for the people you ain't
done squad for the people either at
which point the brothers shut up
comically believe that and what was most
inspiring to me there are a lot of
things were but one of the most
inspiring things and working with them
on it was the extent to which the people
demonstrated that the first day that we
got down to serious work I mean Redmond
planning and we've been meeting with
publishers over in doing so but now
we're gonna work on the book itself and
he says tomorrow Mon and we got to start
over the third well at least six o'clock
seven o'clock the latest because in the
afternoon the people are gonna start to
come you didn't make appointment was
supposed to be working today this is no
first work in this I didn't make any
appointments but the people will come
and lo and behold they did from a one
o'clock in the afternoon
Africans born on the continent Kim
Africans born in this country people
from the Caribbean even some white folk
the people Kim all expressing respect
admiration gratitude for a struggle and
it was a beautiful thing to see because
you could see its strengthening him and
he developed an R and he was very
gracious and outgoing to the people and
I don't know where these people came
from how they got the address out again
but it happened and in the book he says
if I could find a passage I would read
it to you with your indulgence give me a
minute and I'll try and find it okay
I should have marked it before
ah what is humbling about all of this is
that these brothers and sisters and so
many many more have done all that they
have done and it is coming forward to
take care of him now that he is stricken
endured all that they have endured
during an illness that that must have
come to seemed interminable with such
Amazing Grace on feeling generosity I am
very fortunate in my people
I believe my doctors might get a
surprise attempts to the round well they
can thank themselves for that and
certainly the overwhelming spontaneous
outpouring of love and concern in all
sides that has just lifted
I mean lifted my spirits as most people
singing the gospel love lifted me let
the church say Amen I know that this
more than anything else I know that more
than anything else it is this love that
has kept me alive not only has it kept
me alive but this is this love that
tells me convinces me that we're going
to win I can die tomorrow no problem my
people are going to win I know that and
that's an expression of what I witnessed
and every time I'd leave him to go back
to Amherst to write up the notes write
up the stuff he gave me I would be
inspired by that if you struggle for the
people the people will never abandon you
I think the people kept him alive I
really do
taught any of them to finish this book
and so and he would be if he were here I
think he would say this is the people's
book as much as it is my book so he had
the determination he had the unbreakable
will he found the resources and the
energy to leave you this book I put it
in shape and bring it to present it to
you in his name after that is up to you
guys to make of it what you will I think
I will close simply
by reading his obituary which came to me
as being written by him on his deathbed
in Guinea where he was attended I'm on
either people by his son Booker who is
with us
there was no fee I found it this is a
big book you will get your money's worth
I talked to you about that in a minute I
talked to you about awareness I just
read you the PostScript accompanied by
his sister najeev and Alma Dooley a
Guinean friend this is my I'm writing
the sisters in quality Kwame Toure left
New York for the last time on February
July fit on Friday July 5th 1998 the
party arrived in Guinea on Sunday July
7th they were joined there a week later
by Erich Mohammed and a week after that
famous me Charles Carmichael
for the next four months attended by
that group and what I neglected to put
that book of Bureau was also present at
that time and I will put attend a second
edition for the next four months
attended by that group in between
frequent medical crises requiring
hospitalization the brother would
continue to work while receiving a
stream of visitors humble folk and
dignitaries alike I cannot were just
mentioned in one group a group of
visitors from war-torn Mozambique this
delegation consisting of amputees made
their way from that country to Conakry
to greet and salute the brother what
motive I wondered would have brought
simple farmers and old soldiers so great
a distance as it turns out gratitude
upon hearing of their plate earlier the
consequence of landmines and war brother
Tory had brought the matter to the
attention of
Cuban embassy whose government undertook
to supply the man with prosthesis the
group has come all that way merely to
say thanks and to offer prayers and
libations for the brother on November
15th 1998 and exhausted Kwame Toure
weighing less than 100 pounds danced and
went to join the ancestors people from
39 countries came to join his family
friends and a great multitude of Guinean
people for the funeral but the last word
should be his before leaving or brother
peace beyond to him composed and
entrusted to brother Eric Muhammad his
obituary in red ink on a yellow pad he
had written Kwame Toure died in his
beloved Africa affirming that if
Africa's children cannot leave yet her
suffering we can Utley share them fully
one United Socialist Africa for me to a
and that is a postscript to his book the
thing I was gonna say and I wanted to
tell you was in going around talking
about quanis book the response that have
noticed that I know I was about to say
think but I know would be most
gratifying to him is the response from
his people I'm talking about working
class black folk some of them over
another generation or some of them even
quite young some of them you can clearly
see that the price of the book
represents an investment but I feel I
don't feel bad about it because it's a
big book so they're getting their
money's worth and it's a book that they
will enjoy reading because qualm is
spirit and wit an incredible life in
forms and in spirits that book
but when they come up with their books
you can see that whatever the investment
was is something they were proud to make
something they were glad to make and
they want the book saying to their
grandchildren they want a book saying to
their children and it seems to me that
that is absolutely in the spirit to what
kwame intended I think that would please
them very much and other thing that's
it's very strange so the bookstore
people telling me book sellers that the
people start to read the book before
they leave so an accomplice I think you
very enjoy this book as I'm enjoying it
already I read you know such and such
and such so the book has a vitality to
it that I think would certainly please
Kwame and certainly gratifies me as it
should please you with that out pause
and take any questions that you have if
you have questions
it's not certainly sir first of all
thank you for as you said carrying on
the mission he entrusted to you to bring
this book out I'm sure not alone we
appreciate that of my duty our
responsibility anticipation
I wonder if you could talk about for for
those of us who are doing what we can to
carry on his legacy a lot of the work
that we do involves reinventing our own
inspiration and then trying to pass that
inspiration on to others could you talk
a little bit about how he maintained his
own inspiration how was he so confident
in the future of African people or the
world's people when it's so easy thank
you so easy particularly today to look
at the world and to lose hope how do you
have could you talk a little bit about
how he maintained his no that would be
presumptuous to me I have no idea how he
did it what I can't tell you is that
Kwame was not idiot optimist he was a
very hard-headed realistic guy and a
clear-eyed analyst of events that he
maintained his principle and that he
maintained his faith and that he
maintained his commitment is evident to
anybody who knew him but to talk about
how it was that he managed to do that
with the speculation of my part which I
don't really feel prepared to do I know
it had something to do with his courage
I know it has a great need to do with a
kind of sensitivity and compassion and a
sense of justice in the man that is
manifest in the book from a very young
age I mean as our talks about him
carrying food to school to give to
children who didn't have food talked
about a great sense of justice that he
had so what I can tell you I don't know
how he did it well racketeers he was
motivated by us
indignant dislike of injustice a very
rational view that the world had
resources that didn't need to tolerate
the kinds of deprivation and poverty and
oppression many people suffered he had a
very strong sense of history of what his
people had endured and in some way those
came together to give him the will and
the resolve to keep on and the clarity
to know that as Bob Marley would sing
better must come that we in fact will
win that humanity will prevail and that
it is our duty and responsibility and he
said this very often each generation to
carry is fortunate struggling to
continue but how he managed to do that
Angus pickled it but that's what he did
my dad my sister I thought you might
that's why I amended myself the Lord
spoke to my mentality and a change
actually I'd like to address the point
that the brother raised about how how we
think he might've dealt with a struggle
but before I do that I want to share
something light-hearted thing in 1994 I
went to Uganda to I was attending a
pan-african conference and people from
all over the world were there and in
1994 OSD is pan-african Congress and
there was this tall handsome man and I'm
from the Caribbean as you can tell so
well there's a British thing in it but
I'm from the qat an unnaturally tall man
I think I'm pretty so I started flirting
with this guy it wasn't and this this
gentleman it is very basic Trinidadian
accent took me on and we were they
you know and eventually somebody said
for me and I thought oh I looked at em I
see
are you Stokely Carmichael and he smiled
but the time when I discovered who he
was I didn't have enough time to get to
know the gentleman but I asked two big
questions about the struggle and of
course when he was asked to speak the
Caribbean bit went and then I could hear
the revolutionary American you know type
thing and he really his I was inspired I
really really was here is somebody with
such a claim could maintain his his
origin as it were today extended he was
he was in a cold and I didn't know him
I'll do if I saw his picture I would
know it was him but the other thing that
is remarkable
I came to DC some four years ago and
there's a person with whom I confide and
he's my mentor kind of thing and every
other day he would remind me Stokely
Carmichael says we're all in this
chopper no matter what what little you
do if it's even to light the fire and
cook the food while we a struggling
that's your contribution to the struggle
and every day I take that I mean that I
know my strength so I would take that as
part of the struggle and I think Stokely
saw himself he's he identified his role
and that is what he was going to stick
to and for other people he identified
their role and he encouraged him no
matter how meager to it was he felt it
was better that and I think I would like
to remember him for that the thing I'd
like to ask you though is I don't know
how much you know of Malcolm X and
Farrakhan but one thing that is common
among those three is that they are of
Caribbean origin can you explain why
that it why it is we seem to be so
firebrand and creating what others might
because sometimes I'm called a lunatic
Stalin when you talk when you're brave
and address issues can you explain why
that common thread in the first place if
we started to count the people black
people of Caribbean origin in this
country and their descendants we would
have an exceeding large number and of
that number you identify Marcus Garvey
you didn't put time surrender been you
identified fire can you identify Malcolm
X who incidentally wasn't Caribbean his
mother had some carbon touches and so
that and you could identify him
of course brother Kwame that leaves
several million who are not firebrand
and tearing on the place you know
whoever integrated very well into the
society and trying to make their way I
mean for every Kwame Toure but no I was
about to say forever Kwame Toure there's
a coolant oil but that's not true
they're not many quark they're not many
Kwame to reason out many current pose so
let's not just generalize the Caribbean
in that way my sister but am
and my association with Carmichael he
would we all African people
he wouldn't distinguish Caribbean
research whenever we do it actually a
couple of things about it sometimes see
I'm going veer from the subject now you
do encounter nothing your kids were you
do encounter a kind of unseemly
Caribbean chauvinism in fact I went one
sister a Caribbean audience we had a
brilliant inspired an eloquent speech
for which I've never been paid because
because I gave them a lecture on that
kind of chauvinism and the fact is you
know the ships left the west coast of
Africa and they could have stopped in
Brazil they could have stopped in
Barbados they could have stopped in
Kingston Jamaica they could have stopped
in godless they could have stopped in
New Orleans so where you got off the
ship I could have stopped in Havana Cuba
port-au-prince City where you got off
the ship will dominate a very artificial
sense of nationality but the fact is
where you got off the ship isn't what or
isn't what defined you we are as Kwame
would say and African people and I'm
going to dress precisely the Caribbean
chauvinism aspect of it no I was at this
place and people were telling them oh
very special and militant and
accomplished and in and and well endowed
Caribbean people were especially young
people as opposed to African Americans
very unfortunate and Burma's misguided
and very incorrect and I simplicity I
must say look there is no right you have
in this country there is no program that
you have access to there is no
opportunity that is given to you that
wasn't bought and paid for by the
bloodshed by african-americans and
generations of struggle and the African
American community didn't want to
struggle for their own liberation but
they in fact deepened the clearance of
American democracy
and the entitlements of all citizens in
this country and all you immigrants come
in you're behind that should understand
that very carefully for which reason
that wasn't paid so if you want to think
of a collection to give you that fear
never God
I would accept it I know are there any
other questions madam doctor there well
again I want to say thank you for
assisting if you will for me in his
writing an autobiography I want to pose
a question to you I'm not joking if
somebody whom you had known for 37 years
who had dedicated their life with such
single-mindedness and such Grace and
such good humor to the liberation of our
our giant peoples and done it so
selflessly came to you and asked you to
assist in a certain kind of project what
possibility was there for you to other
than do it and if he if he displayed the
confidence his last words to me the
message I got back from Carnac viewers
tell that was to finish the book and not
to forget Africa if you had confidence
that I could do it in accordance with
his instructions and his spirit I didn't
have any choice did I I mean it's an
obligation and a duty of honour of
friendship to history and didn't have
any ties so there's no need for anybody
to thank me Kwami thanked me by
entrusting it to me rephrase they're
artists and kwame we all just act
quality throughout the years have begged
him for many many years
to sit down and write a book if not need
obviously I don't have time sister about
organizing 20 years ago this year
I told Kwame in the living room of my
house in Oklahoma University Oklahoma
Norman why me why don't you write a book
and he gave that response I need to give
me that similarly for other people over
the years you know how their response to
I thought we had another response people
who said to me ought to write to your
autobiography ought to write to that
store you owe it to history and you'd
say you know where's my life story more
important than any other I'm just
another revolutionary out there I don't
think that was false modesty inspired
either he really felt that you're very
reluctant to talk about himself and
that's why things that inhibited him I
couldn't help but notice and so the last
time I saw I'm now halfway through the
book when I saw you two weeks ago I was
just started and now I'm halfway through
ah
what is your I'm loving it why no I want
I wanted your peers and brothers and
sisters to hear a good biased you know
one thing for reading the book though
that I cannot help but notice that in a
lot of passages Kwame speaks in very
spiritual and local terms what I found
was very striking to me and I'm a good
little church sister and I'm not I'm not
accustomed to quality talking like that
that often you know I mean I've been in
meetings with him the last at the six
hour well he didn't call the name of
Jesus you know I mean so if you could
just share cuz I'm curious about that
aspect I mean he was like Jesus and
Christ and this than the other
okay you know were you talking to go I
don't know exactly what you mean he just
he'd use a lot of biblical reference
system and and terms you said you always
use biblical references fishermen
organizing in the South but I mean if
you could read a passage that I'd like
to hear what you're talking about
because you're making the Sun is a
corner got all too pious and was a
born-again preacher that's not my
recollection
maybe the Cystic mind but Toni Morrison
mentioned on the radio as she was
talking about her students in New York
and she stated that she has Stokely
Carmichael in before he went one of the
tours in the south he was on his way to
theology school that's what she said on
the radio they wanted to become a
minister first of all you read the book
you know that's he said though - yeah
yeah I know I know
no no no no I understand we're it's not
untrue but he really went too hard to go
to med school but he's made it very
clear and that in the culture and
environment of his family where he grew
up there are only three alternatives
professional alternatives for black men
that offered any possibility of
independence from the tentacles of white
folk
one was the ministry because the
congregation would take carrier the
other one was medicine and the third one
was the law and he said those were there
and given his love of language and
personal flamboyant those were the
career alternatives discussed in his
family then on another occasion he talks
about his aunt Maura Olga who was very
religious and some televangelist said if
you read two chapters of
you could read the Bible in a certain
number of months and then this guy would
come on and talk about the two things so
he was drafted in about age of fourteen
thirteen to read the Bible two chapters
a day with mommy alga and to listen to
this guy and but he does say that the
ministry was one of the options
seriously discussed in the family and
many people in the family being
religious probably would have acted for
that you know it was kind of a trade-off
between that and medicine so it comes
from that but a lot of that language as
a language of Southern culture which he
picked up in Mississippi but I don't
think I think he uses it in a in a
rhetorical way as opposed to a spiritual
kind of preaching right now so much as
much as I can see if you can read me a
passage maybe we could see where your
talk that question answers itself my
sister and if you want if you want the
secret to rather crawl is
autobiographical discuss it with them to
add only person can write the secret -
kwame's book is Kwame let me just say
let me just say that the notion of a
secret had never occurred to me giving
you extensive instructions about
publishing the book are there any that
you can share with us
Ben signs here very clear see first of
all he read several chapters I'm not at
the instruction came when we sat down to
go over those chapters and some of those
sessions were even tipped which I
thought was kinda unnecessary we just
editing the chapters right here but but
they were tipped and there proved very
instructive after he was gone but let me
tell you a story you have to bear in
mind that when we be gone the odds
against us a finding a publisher were
very very great which major American
corporate publisher is going to invest
in a book by a man with a project
protracted life span of six months so
that was almost impossible yet it
happened and then at a certain point I
mean I could have done a different book
if Kwame had died I could have taken a
lot of the material he'd given me and
wrote a biography of Kwame Toure which
would not be his autobiography I would
have to live in my language I could have
interpreters I could have done research
a clear written a biography it would
have been the first biography
requirement or is it would have probably
had some prominence but it would have
been my book my property not yes did and
I didn't want to do that so I really
wanted him to have his autobiography it
was his life and there were people
floating around the place who are
talking about earning large sums by
writing a biography of Kwame Toure and I
thought young man is sick he has nothing
because he has not looked for anything
outside a service to his people and his
life is about to become a commodity to
earn money for somebody else I mean
there's nothing dishonest about it why
writers do it all the time but it struck
me as strange and that's why I thought
he ought to write his book himself you
know as far as your instructions are
concerned
at a certain point he got very weak and
I said you know listen if you're going
shuffle off and go someplace I need to
know exactly what you want done or I can
go forward with this and I got to know
that you understand exactly what I'm
doing or I can go forward with it so
what I will do is do a treatment do you
know what the treatment is it's a term
from cinema tada gee and the wealthy
people who produce cinema and not the
brightest people in the world so when
you do a treatment you would describe
every scene what you don't have
necessarily have a doubt I would you
describe what happens or what it means
and very clear is so they can see it and
you do that for the whole film it's
called a treatment so I decided to do a
treatment of the book to describe every
chapter every issue how it would go
knowing that took a based on a stiff but
the kind of shape I would give it and I
said to him this is for you to look at
and discuss we when I come we can
discuss it so I will know that if you're
not here I have your very precise
instructions and we have an agreement
those are kind of a document of
agreement stayed up all night doing it
when I got to about chapter 15 I
realized I couldn't do it for every
chapter so I summarized and I said
there's certain issues we need to
discuss you've given me information and
how I should represent them on the peers
and I made certain suggestions and it
came to seventeen and a half pages and I
know exactly how many pages that came to
not the car counted them but because of
what then happened so I jump in my car
and I go to New York to work with them
get their vote four o'clock in the
morning and I said Kwame here's the
treatment to talk to your vote we start
working in the morning but sometime
before I leave I want you to read this
so we can discuss it so I don't know if
you are called for in that phone I don't
know what you need to be done I tell you
have very clear instructions as I know
what you want otherwise I can go on with
this book I can do it in your name I
said all right said we get some sleep we
start work in the morning
so I gave him the document Wrentham Abed
got hippo go into the room we started
talking started to work for what couple
hours and then I said Oh
Kwame my brother did you you couldn't
possibly have read that document I
brought to you it you have to find some
time today to do it and I really wanted
to discuss to you before I leave and you
reach on this below it put a look at the
document looked at me I handed it to me
now bear in mind that all had intended
was clarification he saw it in very
political terms he wrote read understood
agreed
Kwame Toure the date and seventeen and a
half pages do you understand what a
politically Institute Act that was he
even put in number of pages in case I
added some creatures he one said what I
read understood and agreed to us
seventeen and a half pages you put the
date and say you know what you important
me to go along with this process kind o
understand what you want but you also
have given me evidence that I understand
it I mean I wasn't thinking in those
terms I just wanted some force to talk
about and to clarify my brother that
response makes me want to rephrase that
says this question your honor fixin to
continue sir no as a friend and as a
friend of Stoke please hmm and now
that's the autobiography is out and as a
writer
are you thinking about or would you
consider a biography think of Stokely
and do you think that that would be
valuable biography or even oh stop y'all
done snuck up on me alright
forgive me the last two childhood Steven
if I sit down and avoid certain time to
write in anything it would be valuable
but as far as the as far as the
biography of story is concerned that
depends on what happens you know there's
one thing I do intend to write it's not
a secret but I went into this whole
operation with a great many adults that
he would live long enough first to be
able to do it and also the great many
anxieties about how do you spend time
with a good friend which Martin who's
dying I never had that experience before
it turned out to be one of the most
inspiring experiences of my life and the
reasons for that are interesting and I
miss sit down and write just an account
of working with Carmichael on this book
because there's some great great stories
some funny stories he never lost a sense
of humor I tell you one funny story and
then I see people that proprietors
looking Restless women going too young
but when I first started working the
notion of his condition is terminal
condition very heavy on my mind what
people would come in and see us and it's
a the new armor right to sit empty
writing a book quote Stokely I said no
no no that's the biography we've been
talking about I said no no no I'm not
writing a book quote Stokely and then I
would look for an image that they would
recognize to explain the nature of the
operation and a relationship and I'd say
remember Alex helium Malcolm I'm doing
for Stokely
what Alex did for Malcolm and the
autobiography my collectors ah we
understand and they would leave so I set
up both three times the fourth time
somebody came in the Enquirer Merced in
the bedroom working and I said it again
but I got halfway through it and I
remembered something and so I stopped
you maybe can't figure out what I
remembered well when I stopped Kwame
looked at me and as I say remember Alex
helium Malcolm well and I stopped to say
no I know a better way call me the king
I'm the grill
I am the King's grill I'm recording the
language he loves African culture so
think of it that way I'm recalling the
language of the King and I'm giving it
shape and form I'm the Kings griot the
king was historian and he grinned at me
and then but he knew exactly why I had
stopped you know why I had stopped
because at a certain point in that
process Malcolm had said to Alex you
know I'm not going to read this book and
I remembered that and call me new yet
that's what I remember because soon as
he lifted grin at me and says also you
the Kings griot say yep he said well do
you know that what they do to the grill
and the King does and I said BS I said
the Brio is history I can't kill history
nobody does that you think another
king's horseman and that play viola
shalinka
and he had to admit it at Huachuca
nobody kills the griot the Gredos is
history is the story so there are lots
of stuff and so it after that it became
easy for us to deal with his pending
mortality and there lots of lots of
stories about that process that might
shed some light on the book but even
more so shed some light on Kwame so I am
II write that as very short essay
maybe longer but that's about all that
plan to do now but have it the reviews
have started to come in and they have
been very interested so never say never
I want to read you something here I'm
talking about in the collaborators note
exactly what the book is on what it
isn't of course that your work has to be
the result of collaboration but it's not
a biography it is Kwame Torres account
of his life
and political career it is his story
that portion of his personal political
and intellectual life which he wished to
share with posterity hence an
autobiography a man's vision of the
events decisions and meaning of his
public life by his account in his
language and in accordance with his
wishes and instruction all public
figures are entitled to such an account
indeed in rare cases such as this one
history we even seemed to demand it
after which all public figures are
entitled to such an account Dubois had
his autobiography malcolm had his
frederick douglass had to all public
figures are entitled to tell this story
in their own terms
indeed in rare cases such as this one
history would even seem to demand it
after which as was the case with Malcolm
the tribe of pedants closeted scholars
nitpickers and hair splitters can come
scratcher on the life on their
revisionist missions but this is the
man's account of his life and intentions
and the rather we used to play dozens
with African proverbs he loved African
proverbs so today the brother was
particularly fond of the wisdom of a
Yoruba proverb which says when an
elephant is killed and the village comes
to share the meat you will see all sizes
and shapes of cutting tools brought to
the task which means everybody will
carve off what they can carry what they
want what they prefer that Squam is life
a lot of scholars and it because and so
on so we'll come and carve on carry off
what it can take and we see that
happening in the reviews already each
villager will carve out and carry off
what they need want or whatever they are
either we expect that it was ever thus
so it depends you know I'm sure people
will write biographies of Kwame
revisionist biographies do it with
Malcolm some of the reviews are a
certain their view of what his life
meant as opposed to his view so that
struggle is going to continue whether or
not
get involved in it like I said I can't
make a career of Kwame Torres life you
know Emma says I'm an old man though uh
I'm looking for the spray so does that
answer your question
no look at one more question okay we
could go on all night and knows more
people yes ma'am
and then the brother okay any
instructions as to who would be the
beneficiary of this work we should be
absolutely there are elaborate legal
documents which I don't care to share
with the public and then there is his
will which I've never seen but as far as
a book is concerned that's very clear
sir and brother I have one concern
actually for everyone one concern you're
fortunate well regarding this work the
first time I got into contact with Kwame
Toure was Adam actually when his picture
I mean I saw his picture there then the
next time I got a little explanation
about who he was who he is was when I
met his friend of mine in our University
for the book and he advised me to get a
copy of it and now told me a little
about quality to me and now my concern
is that a lot I'm coming from the Nevada
and Africa Ghana actually and I my
concern is that a lot of us back home do
not have
enough knowledge to almost no knowledge
about our people who have held up there
I mean the struggles in your life so
that it looks like we are kind of
reluctant or relaxed or we think that
actually is no struggle but all in all a
struggle all around the world I mean
sometimes I have to I think that the
basis will be in the motherland so that
if we don't have any knowledge any I
mean no information as to what is moving
on people are struggling all around gear
towards the motherland and we are
sitting down it looks like so the fight
goes on when it comes home
they're like home is a shambles so my
concern is there's that out I don't know
but I would wish that efforts are made
to get material like this this book
especially and some other books Malcolm
X I got to read about Malcolm X and Gabi
here you know like I would hear little
about them but you don't have the
material we don't have the books I mean
like we don't have access I think I
understand you're right first of all
that was qualms is concerned to I mean
what I think she said very clearly to me
and we're running out directly another
story which was really quite amazing
where the book is going to be translated
for example into Arabic and it's going
to be published by the Supreme Council
on culture of the Egyptian government
and what they do is they get 10 or 12
texts every year from around the world
that the things are important they
translate them into Arabic and they
produce them in a very good production
good paper solid which would be too
expensive for the average reader but
they subsidize it so sold very cheaply
when that happened qualms had already
died but I was so saddened that they
couldn't come back to God he had said to
me I don't want this book to be read
only in America I want this book to be
read on the continent I want it for my
people if I could have comic and place
that
letter from the Supreme Council on
culture center burn translated to Arabic
industries her own the whole of northern
Africa he would have been delighted now
the question is how do we get copies
into the hands of brothers and sisters
in Africa at prices they can afford and
under the rules which govern regulate
international publishing which is a
capitalist rules that's a real problem
I've had that problem with my own books
back in Jamaica but the people that
describe but it is a concern that we
have it's a concern that I have one way
to do it if you can find a good African
publisher and subsidize it so that a
copies can be made not only available
but available in affordable copies let
the book have a career and let the book
do some earning I would give me then the
leverage and the power to raise those
kinds of questions but be assured that
those kinds of questions are in the
forefront of my to the extent that I
have anything to do with the future of
the book okay and I think we have to end
no because
there are some minor trends we got to
end no but they're not covering our own
so but you have no further questions say
that he would say about Africa and it's
like why did he so in Guinea talks about
that very clearly all right friends
enjoy doing this glad to meet you thank
you for being here and now I have to do
another absurdity which is saying form
this book with my names on the cover too
so I guess I have the right to send and
brother Booker ready for revolution the
life and struggles of Stokely Carmichael
is published by Scribner an imprint of
Simon & Schuster visit Simon Says
dot-com for more information next week
on public lives a biography of colonial
clergyman Jonathan at